لذلك دعونا نركز على ما
ننظر إليه العقيد ليون ويمكننا أن نعرض
خريطة هنا عندما نتحدث عن
الأراضي الفلسطينية، فنحن نتحدث بشكل عام
عن الضفة الغربية وغزة ولكننا
هنا نركز فقط على غزة حيث توجد
إسرائيل  تسيطر على البحر على
الحدود الشمالية والحدود الشرقية، كيف يمكن أن
يحدث هذا للقبض على إسرائيل على حين
غرة، نعم هذا
سؤال رائع حقًا أورين لأن ما
تنظر إليه هنا هو هذه المنطقة الصغيرة حقًا
من الأرض وهي مكتظة
بالسكان كما ذكرت  في وقت سابق أه
ولكن حقيقة الأمر هي أن
الفلسطينيين غوريلا حماس كانوا
يبحثون حقًا عن كيفية التحايل على
المخابرات الإسرائيلية وكانوا يعلمون أنه يتعين عليهم
التخلص من الهواتف التي كانوا يعلمون أنه
يتعين عليهم في الأساس استخدام السعاة ووسائل
أخرى أكثر بدائية  اه
للتواصل مع بعضهم البعض وعندما
فعلوا ذلك تمكنوا من ذلك يبدو
وكأنه منع الإسرائيليين من
معرفة ما كانوا يعتزمون فعله حقًا وهذا
أعتقد أنه أعطاهم عنصر المفاجأة
في هذه الحالة تقول وسائل بدائية ومع
ذلك إسرائيل هي  المعروفة بقدرتها
بصراحة على تكنولوجيا التجسس سواء كان ذلك
من الجو أو
اعتراض الإشارات، هل كانت حماس تتجه ببساطة
للتغلب على قدرة إسرائيل على
التقاط أي من هذا، وما كان يجب أن يكون
خلية كبيرة لتنفيذ هذا، نعم
أعتقد أنه كان كذلك  والأمر
المثير للاهتمام حقًا بشأن هذا هو حقيقة
أنك عندما تذهب إلى أه هذه المنطقة
وتنظر إلى جميع
العناصر المختلفة الموجودة هنا،
يمكنك أن ترى أن إسرائيل قد
أحاطت بالفعل بالعديد من المنافسين المختلفين في
هذا  نقطة معينة من الزمن وأعداء سابقين
بعضهم أعداء حاليين
وحقيقة أنهم تمكنوا من
القيام بذلك أعتقد أن يشير إلى أنهم اه
ذهبوا إلى مستوى منخفض من التكنولوجيا من أجل منع
وسائل الكشف عالية التقنية وهذا
سمح لهم اه بالذهاب  في وفي الجوهر
أه فاجئ الإسرائيليين
بطريقة لم يتوقعوها وفي
كثير من النواحي تعتقد أن المفاجآت
هي شيء لا تتوقعه
ولكن هذا أكثر من ذلك فهو يصل
إلى مستوى أعمق من  أن الرئيس
جو بايدن حذر الأطراف الأخرى من
التورط في هذا الصراع ماذا ومن
وأين كان يشير
بهذا التعليق بينما ننظر حول
حدود دولة إسرائيل لذا فإن أحد
الأشياء الرئيسية أعتقد أنه أحد
اللاعبين الرئيسيين  هو هنا في لبنان كما
تعلم عندما تنظر إلى أه القوات
الموجودة هنا تنظر إلى حزب الله
أه المدعوم من إيران وهو خارج
الخريطة على الجانب الآخر هنا تنظر أيضًا
إلى القوات في سوريا أه الكثير منها
أه سبق أن طاردت إسرائيل
أيضًا ثم تنظر بالطبع إلى
الضفة الغربية التي بها منظمة التحرير الفلسطينية أه
ولديك كيانات غير حماس هناك
تعمل بطريقة أه يمكنها أيضًا أن تصطف
ضد إسرائيل ويمكن أن
تتعاطف معها  حماس:
لدي انتفاضة هنا يمكن أن
تؤثر سلباً على كل ما
يحدث في إسرائيل، العقيد ليون، شكراً
لك